d'ouvrir cette circulaire ce matin pour
l'élection de notre nouveau président je
voudrais saluer madame la ministre
merci brigitte je crois qu'un emploi du
temps très chargé d'être là ce matin je
voudrais saluer prise dobly fédéric
connell scellier la presse et bien sur
route et vous tous il y avait pas un
tour d'image qui devrait durer trois
minutes une prise de vue de la salle que
le minou 10 le service communication
c'est bon on peut avancer bien j'invite
la benjamine de notre assemblée
c'est lara million aujourd'hui à me
rejoindre
voilà je lui demanderais de faire
l'appel
daniel adrian pierre ville patricia
bonne
alain couche ou max delmond martin
dietrich
sabine drexler pascal ferrari
alain grappe bernadette groff habig
michel bleus dont vincent hagenbach
alors emilie helderlé est excusé et
donne procuration à monsieur bill
il est ménagé d'accord ni que l'agent
d'air est excusé et donne procuration à
madame drexler fatima yens brigitte
klinkert annick lutenbacher monique
martin josiane mehlen vetere lara
million présente betty muller lucien
muller marque unique
fabienne orlandi karine pagliarulo
catherine rap marc chikli
pascale schmidiger eric straumann
philippe trimaille marie france va la
pierre vote et rémy vite
merci lara je rappelle les dispositions
du quorum le conseil départemental ne
peut délibérer que si les deux tiers de
ses membres sont présents
si cette condition n'est pas remplie la
réunion se tient de plein droit trois
jours plus tard la réunion peut alors
avoir lieu sans condition de quorum
mais là je constate que le corps est
largement atteint nous pouvons donc
valablement délibérer séance je les dis
en entrée assez particulière puisque les
événements nous font que nous devons
trouver un nouveau président
donc je crois que c'est avec plaisir que
tout à l'heure et je me réjouis de
l'unanimité de 2,2 de notre groupe est
de 9,2 au groupe pour pouvoir avancer
d'une manière sereine dans les quelques
mois qui nous reste à voir l'avènement
de la pelouse de la communauté
européenne d'alsace nous allons procéder
sans délai à l'élection du président du
conseil départemental
le jeu demande si il y à des candidats
je rappelle quand même que le président
est élu à la majorité absolue des
membres conseil départemental donc 18
si cette élection n'est pas acquise
après les deux premiers tours de scrutin
et procédé un troisième tour l'élection
a lieu à la majorité relative des
membres du conseil départemental au cas
d'égalité des voix l'élection est
acquise au bénéfice de l'âge il n'est
pas nécessaire d'avoir fait acte de
candidature pour être élu président
voilà y'a t'il les candidats alors pour
le compte de du groupe majoritaire unis
pour le haut-rhin je propose la
candidature de monsieur rémy vite
y aura-t-il d'autres candidats vous
notre candidature
je constate que ce n'est pas le cas et
je déclare ouvert le scrutin
marc chikli
philippe trimaille
il
fatima yens
catherine rapt
passe comme ça mais chelle habib
l'argent millions
pascale schmidiger
max delmond
pierre bihl qui a une procuration celle
de madame helderlé emilie aussi
lucien muller
monique martin
marie-france vallat
et et pierre boxe
rémy bits
et m'évite rémy dit rémi vie rémi vie
rémi vite
rémy vie rémi vie rémi dit rémi dit rémi
vite réglé
rémy vite dit dernier rémy bits
rémy vite
rémy dit rémi vie et milite rémy 8
remili rémy vite
rémy 8 et rémy dit voilà donc 33 votes
pour rémy vite et un bulletin blanc
avec toutes mes félicitations monsieur
le président
[Applaudissements]
je vous invite à prendre
merci pour cette belle unanimité mais la
réglementation veut que les discours se
fasse après leurs deux d'interruption
donc je vais respecter cru
scrupuleusement le règlement et donc il
m'appartient sens sans m'étendre
davantage de vous proposer la mise en
place de la commission permanente
l'élection des vice-présidents et des
autres membres de la cpi je vous
rappelle le code électoral conformément
aux dispositions de l'article l 31-22 de
l 31-22 ktl 31 22 5 du code général des
collectivités territoriales les règles
applicables sont les suivantes en
matière de la de commissions permanentes
la commission permanente est composée du
président du conseil départemental de 4
à 15 vice président sous réserve que le
nombre de ceux ci ne soit pas supérieure
à 30% de l'effectif du conseil
départemental et éventuellement d'un ou
plusieurs autres membres
pour le conseil départemental du
haut-rhin jusqu'ici nous avions dit vice
président ce qui correspondait à 30 % de
la composition de l'assemblée
départementale et l'ensemble des membres
de l'assemblée départementale faisait
partie de la commission permanente comme
d'ailleurs c'est le cas dans certains
départements et notamment chez nos amis
bas rhinois je crois qu'ils ont
également en application cette formule
donc je vous propose donc pour la
composition de la commission permanente
outre le président qui est membre de
droit de vous prononcer sur 10 siège de
vice-président et 23 sièges d'autres
membres
d autres membres de l'assemblée donc une
commission permanente complète des 34
élus départementaux là les vice
présidents seront dans l'ordre du
tableau premier deuxième troisième
en revanche les 23 autres sièges seront
présentés dans le cadre d'une d'une
liste alphabétique en alternance femmes
home donc tout à l'heure donc nous
aurons à voter tout à l'heure après la
reprise de notre séance
la composition ou les membres de la
commission permanente
mais pour l'instant je vous demande de
vous prononcer sur la composition c'est
à dire président de droit dit siège de
vice-président et 23 sièges de
conseillers départementaux
je mets aux voix cette composition est
ce qu'il y à des oppositions
est ce qu'il y a des abstentions quels
sont les votes favorables
là aussi je constate que c'est une belle
unanimité et je vous en remercie donc le
votez donc ainsi proclamé dit
vice-président 23 sièges de membres
départementaux et donc il m'appartient
maintenant de se prononcer tout à
l'heure l'interruption de séance
juste pour rappeler la règle au cas où
sait-on jamais que chaque conseiller
départemental peut présenter une liste
de candidats puisque les candidats à la
commission départementale sont votées
par liszt même incomplète cette liste
mais que nul ne peut figurer sur plus de
deux listes à la fois il faut également
garantir la parité
chacune des lices devra présenter
alternativement candidat de chaque sexe
le sexe du candidat en tête de liste et
sans lien avec le sexe du président élu
les dix premiers noms de la liste son
vice président donc voilà c'est la règle
que je me devais de vous énoncez même si
à partir du moment où tout le monde et
est sur une liste et que tout le monde
est membre de la commission permanente
on peut difficilement mener une deuxième
liste c'était juste pour la petite
anecdote
donc voilà donc une heure de
d'interruption séance et réglementaires
je suis désolé même si notre unanimité
au vaincu nous faire penser qu'on aurait
peut-être pu se passer de cette heure de
suspension mais les de droit elle est
obligatoire
donc si vous me permettez il est 9
heures 57
je prononce la suspension séances d'une
heure à 10h57
nous nous retrouvons dans cette salle
merci à vous mesdames et messieurs chers
collègues
il est 10 heures 57 jeu lors de
suspension est arrivé à son terme
j'ouvre donc la séance pour la deuxième
partie de notre notre réunion
je constate que qu'une seule liste m'a
été remise pour la composition de la
commission permanente et donc je vais
vous en donner lecture composition de la
commission permanente liste des
candidats aux différents postes à
pourvoir
brigitte klinkert première vice
présidente pierre bihl deuxième vice
président josiane melaine vetere 3e vice
présidente michel habig quatrième vice
président bernadette groff 5e vice
présidente alain grappe 6ème vice
président
la ram ion 7e vice présidente
max delmond 8e vice président karine
pagliarulo 9e 10 présidente nicolas
jander 10e vice président ensuite les
autres membres de la commission
permanente dans l'ordre alphabétique
mais en alternat femmes hommes
patricia bonne daniel adrian martin
dietrich
alain couchot sabine drexler pascal
ferrari
emilie elle de relais vincent again bac
fatima yens yves est ménagé annick
lutenbacher lucien muller monique martin
marc mook betty muller eric straumann
fabienne orlandi marc chikli
catherine rap philippe trimaille pascale
schmidiger pierre fock tu marie france
va là je soumets à votre approbation ou
à votre vote
cette liste êtes vous favorable à
l'élection à la commission permanente de
la liste que je viens de vous lire
veuillez lever la main merci à vous y at
il des oppositions y at il des
abstentions je n'en vois pas la liste
est donc la liste des candidats qui sont
où les candidats qui figurent sur cette
liste sont tous
élu à la commission permanente je vais
maintenant appeler mes quatre
vice-présidents de pour me rejoindre
autour de la table présidentielle à
savoir brigitte klinkert pierre bihl
josiane mme hélène et michel habig venez
rejoignez moi
on va essayer de garder la distanciation
mais je pense que pour les quatre
personnes supplémentaires on devrait
pouvoir trouver une répartition
merci madame la première vice-présidente
d'être à mes côtés merci et puis josiane
et donc c'est le moment est venu pour
mon discours officiel
bien madame la ministre
chers collègues je vous remercie très
chaleureusement de la confiance que vous
venez de me témoigner en me portant à la
présidence de notre assemblée
votre vote me touche sincèrement car il
résonne en moi comme une marque de
reconnaissance celle du travail effectué
pendant de très nombreuses années à la
fois dans mon territoire mais également
ici à colmar dans le cadre de mes
fonctions de premier vice président
notamment aux côtés d'eric straumann et
de brigitte klinkert que je tiens
d'ailleurs à remercier tous les deux en
votre nom à tous pour leur dévouement à
la tête de cette collectivité
je pense qu'on peut les applaudir votre
choix mes chers collègues m'honore tout
particulièrement et m'oblige au moins
tout autant
et vous savez à quel point ceci n'est
pas une formule convenue de ma part car
quand j'accepte je m'engage
oui je m'engage devant vous et devant
les haut rhinois à tout mettre en oeuvre
avec toute la vigueur et toute la
détermination que vous me connaissez
afin que notre département soit à la
hauteur des enjeux essentiels qu'il
devra affronter durant les quatre
prochains mois quatre mois qui nous
séparent de l'avènement de la nouvelle
collectivité alsacienne et qui seront le
tout dernier cdd contrat à durée
déterminée pour un président de conseil
départemental du haut rhin
voilà un contrat dont je pourrais
difficilement oublier l' échéance
puisqu'elle ne sera rappelée chaque jour
par le compte à rebours qui défilent sur
la façade du bâtiment
mais trêve de plaisanterie façon aux
choses
rieuse parmi les défis que nous aurons à
relever ensemble chers collègues il y a
tout d'abord dans notre département si
meurtri par l'épidémie de l'aco vide
celui de la gestion de l'après crise
sanitaire et de ses graves conséquences
tant sur l'activité économique que sur
l'emploi je crois pouvoir dire que notre
conseil départemental sous la conduite
de brigitte klinkert a su être très
réactif aux côtés des principales
victimes de cette crise en multipliant
ses actions et ses soutiens avec
rapidité et beaucoup d'efficacité
bravo et merci à toi brigitte nous
restons bien entendu pleinement
mobilisés sur ce front et saurons nous
adapter aux circonstances
ainsi en tant que représentant de la
collectivité chef de file dans le
domaine de la solidarité nous devrons
probablement faire face à une
multiplication des situations de
précarité précarité et d'exclusion
par ailleurs en tant qu'élu sérieusement
préoccupés par l'avenir de nos jeunes
nous devrons continuer à favoriser leur
épanouissement et leur réussite tard ils
sont sans doute les principales victimes
à moyen et à long terme de la crise
économique en cours
enfin je tiens à ce que notre
collectivité se montre vigilante et
exemplaire dans la prévention d'une
éventuelle deuxième vague de l'épidémie
c'est pourquoi j'appelle chacun de nous
qu'ils soient élus ou collaborateurs un
respect scrupuleux des mesures de
protection préconisées par les autorités
sanitaires
il en va de notre santé de celle de nos
concitoyens mais aussi de celle de nos
entreprises et de nos associations
il est possible que nous traversions
encore quelques périodes délicates à
cause du coronavirus mais nous les
surmonterons en gardant notre cap et en
nous souvenant de cette phrase de
charles de gaulle soyons fermes
pure et fidèle au bout de nos peines
il y a la plus grande gloire du monde
celle des hommes qui n'ont pas cédé
sous-entendu femmes et hommes bien
entendu le deuxième objectif que nous
devons poursuivre ensemble durant ces
prochains mois consiste tout simplement
à continuer à exercer nos compétences à
conduire nos politiques et à mener des
actions les actions prévues dans le
cadre du budget 2010 je m'inscris
évidemment dans leur parfaite continuité
il s'agit avant tout de finir les
chantiers qui peuvent l'être de
poursuivre sans perdre de temps les
travaux en cours et de lancer les
opérations qui ont pris du retard suite
à la crise sanitaire
l'économie a absolument besoin de
travail parmi les échéances
incontournable des jours et semaines à
venir il y a bien sûr la rentrée
scolaire 2020-2021 qui aura lieu
vous le savez dans les conditions
sanitaires extrêmement particulière du
côté du conseil départemental je crois
pouvoir dire que nous avons fait le
nécessaire pour que cette année scolaire
se déroule au mieux dans nos collèges
conformément à notre stratégie prêt pour
la réussite éducative de tous
des travaux ont été menés dans de
nombreux établissements afin d'améliorer
les conditions d'accueil et
d'enseignement
l'une des opérations les plus
emblématiques de ceux dans ce domaine et
celle du nouveau collège kennedy de
mulhouse dont les travaux vont durer 28
mois et s'élèveront à plus de 15
millions d'euros
si je les votes devant vous aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu en prévision de cette
rentrée le chantier a nécessité un
transfert des élèves vers l'ancien lycée
claudel qu'il a fallu préalablement
remettre en état pour un montant global
de 520 mille euros de travaux
des mesures d'accompagnement ont
également été prises et mises en place
en étroite concertation avec la ville de
mulhouse la m2a et les services de
l'éducation nationale
que je salue et que je remercie
chaleureusement dans nos autres domaines
de compétence de nombreux dossiers
devront avancer d'ici la fin de l'année
il en va ainsi de certains travaux
routiers structurants de notre politique
de développement territorial dont les
programmes représentent des soutiens
indispensables pour les communes et les
intercommunalités et bien évidemment de
nos actions en faveur de la transition
énergétique
si fondamental dans le contexte de
l'après fessenheim je tiens aussi à
évoquer notre importante contribution à
deux stratégies nationales dans le
domaine de la solidarité
l'une pour la lutte contre la pauvreté
l'autre pour la protection de l'enfance
je veux enfin parler de notre stratégie
or dont je rappelle qu'elle préfigure le
rôle fondamental corps à la collectivité
européenne d'alsace en matière
transfrontalière notamment et qui
continuera à se décliner au fil des
prochaines semaines à travers des
réalisations très concrètes
par exemple la démarche recrutent
or mené avec l ternes alsace pour le
recrutement d'intervenants bilingue en
milieu scolaire ou encore l'application
numérique
or du rhin qui sera lancé à destination
des jeunes pour favoriser
l'apprentissage de langues de la langue
de nos voisins revenons-en à présent à
notre troisième objectif
il s'agit bien sûr de cette toute
dernière ligne droite que nous allons
emprunter ensemble avec nos
collaborateurs en direction de la
collectivité européenne d'alsace 7 cea
que nous avons appelée de nos voeux que
nous avons obtenu de la part de l'état
et qu'il nous appartient d'organiser en
étroite concertation avec nos amis bas
rhinois dans l'intérêt de toutes les
alsaciens et de tous les alsaciens
sachez que j'aborde ce troisième défi
avec confiance et sérénité mais aussi et
surtout avec un très grand sens des
responsabilités
tout d'abord parce que comme vous chers
collègues je suis naturellement alsacien
est donc particulièrement fier de
pouvoir porter ce beau projet jusqu'à
son terme avec j'en suis convaincu
l'appui déterminant et déterminé de
madame la ministre qui m'a précédé dans
cette mission et qui m'accompagnera
durant les quatre prochains mois
ensuite parce que je suis comme vous
chers collègues profondément haut
rhinois est donc particulièrement
soucieux de voir notre département
prendre toute sa place dans la
construction
l'organisation et le fonctionnement de
la future collectivité
enfin parce que je suis viscéralement
sundgauviens et donc comme vous chers
collègues particulièrement attaché à mon
territoire et à ses habitants un
territoire dont je connais chaque
parcelle d habitants dont je connais
quasiment chaque visage n'est ce pas
fabienne comme vous je tiens donc à ce
que la cea deviennent cette collectivité
de proximité garante d'efficacité que
nous avons imaginé avec nos homologues
bas rhinois une collectivité dynamique
innovante créative et ouverte sur ses
voisins allemands et suisses
comme vous je tiens à ce que la cea
devienne la collectivité des territoires
naturellement transversale et non l'une
de ces structures centralisées et
verticale dans notre pays se montrent si
souvent adeptes comme vous je tiens à ce
que la ce a devienne la collectivité de
l'équité de l' équilibre et de la
complémentarité entre nos différents
territoires du sundgau à l'outre-forêt
des bords du rhin au sommet des vosges
du plus petit village aux agglomérations
de colmar mulhouse et strasbourg
comme vous je tiens à ce que la cea soit
conçu avec une tête bien faite est
solide et qu'elle avance sur ses deux
jambes l'une bas-rhinoise l'autre
noise sans jamais boiter ni trébucher
comme vous je tiens à ce que la soa
devienne la collectivité de toutes les
alsaciennes et de tous les alsaciens et
elle le sera car elle saura incarner les
valeurs qui ont toujours fait la force
de l'alsace notamment l'esprit de
solidarité
la volonté d'entreprendre le goût de
l'excellence et le sens de l'engagement
oui chers collègues nous pouvons avoir
confiance en notre capacité à construire
cette nouvelle collectivité à faire en
sorte qu'elles portent toutes les
ambitions de l'alsace et qu'elle
balayera ainsi les doutes des éventuels
sceptiques
l'économiste américain stuart chase a
écrit pour ceux qui croient aucune
explication aucune explication n'est
nécessaire pour ceux qui ne croient pas
aucune explication n'est suffisante moi
j'y crois et j'y crois d'autant plus que
je bénéficierai des compétences de notre
direction générale à l'appel jacob toute
ma confiance mais aussi de la compétence
de celle de l'ensemble de nos cadres et
agents par avance je les remercie très
sincèrement de leur présence à mes côtés
les quatre mois qui vont suivre seront
forcément intense et exigeant pour
chacune et pour chacun d'entre nous mais
nous savons qu'en relevant les défis qui
se présentent à nous nous ferons avancer
le haut rhin nous ferons avancer
l'alsace et nous avancerons avec eux car
comme le disait si bien andré malraux
l'homme ne se construit qu'en
poursuivant ce qui le dépasse
je vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
merci pour ces applaudissements et cette
adhésion massive à ce message
merci bien
il m'appartient maintenant de demander
s'il y a d'autres intervenants si
d'autres collègues souhaitent prendre la
parole monsieur pierre bihl vous avez la
parole merci président mesdames
messieurs chers collègues nous sommes
réunis ce matin pour un moment important
de la vie de notre collectivité
dans quelques minutes nous allons nous
allons élire le dernier président du
conseil départemental du haut rhin
en fait nous l'avons élu je vous le
confirme
j'allais dire y'en a un autre maintenant
nous savons que le dernier président du
conseil départemental du haut rhin
vous le savez l'instant est historique
et solennelle temps les responsabilités
sont grandes et encourageante pour
l'avenir
c'est pas que le discours était prévu de
d'être à d'autres endroits
l'avenir justement c'est celui de
l'alsace et la naissance dans quelques
semaines de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace depuis 2015 et la mise en place
de la réforme territoriale
nous nous sommes battus pour faire
respecter les particularités les
spécificités et les forces de notre
territoire nous avons su nous rassembler
derrière un projet dans le seul et
unique but de faire rayonner nos
richesses
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes plus qu'à 126
jours de l'avènement de cette nouvelle
collectivité nous pouvons le dire nous
sommes définitivement tourné vers
l'avenir l'un des moteurs de la cea
vous le savez tous ce sera la proximité
la crise actuelle nous l'a une nouvelle
fois démontré le département est
l'échelon de cohérence de bon sens et de
pragmatisme
dès le début nous nous sommes mobilisés
auprès des acteurs de terrain hôpitaux
services sociaux et de santé monde
économique filière touristique filière
associative mais aussi et avant tout
auprès des communes qui représentent le
premier échelon de proximité
les communes qui constituent le premier
rempart face aux difficultés de nos
concitoyens se doivent en effet d'être
soutenu l'intelligence des territoires
n'est pas une vaine expression c'est une
réalité
durant cette crise nous avons également
su travailler avec nos voisins allemands
et suisses
en unissant nos forces et nos moyens
pour sauver des vies et combattre
l'épidémie
la coopération transfrontalière en sort
inévitablement renforcer et prouve que
notre destin est intimement lié à
l'espace rhénan et ses valeurs de
fraternité et de solidarité
ces valeurs qui vous sont chers madame
la ministre chère brigitte et au nom du
groupe uni pour le haut rhin que j'ai la
chance de présider
je vous adresse une nouvelle fois plus
que nos félicitations pour votre
nomination au gouvernement
chère brigitte nous connaissons toutes
vos qualités votre engagement inlassable
dans l'ensemble des projets que vous
entreprenez votre énergie est
communicative et votre détermination ont
su dans bien des situations faire la
différence
merci brigitte pour toute son action à
la tête de notre collectivité
nous comptons bien évidemment sur vous
madame la ministre afin de faire
entendre la voix de l'alsace au plus
haut sommet de l'état
mais rien n'aurait été possible sans
l'ensemble des membres de notre
assemblée
nous avons toujours travaillé ensemble
avec conviction face aux défis qui se
mais devant nous tous nous avons su
faire rayonner notre collectivité au
plus proche de tous les espaces de notre
département en soutenant des projets
majeurs
je pense en premier lieu à la nécessaire
réussite de la recrue reconversion du
site de fessenheim
je pense aussi aux travaux du barrage de
kruth à la rénovation de nos collèges et
de nos ehpad
sans oublier la valorisation de notre
patrimoine
fidèle serviteur du département depuis
sa première élection en 1979 alors j'ai
fait les comptes
ça fait il ya quarante et une années sur
le canton de dannemarie devenu entre
temps celui de masevaux rémy vite n'a eu
de cesse d'ancrer notre collectivité
dans le quotidien des haut rhinoises et
des haut rhinois comme il aime à le
rappeler et il ya de le faire tout à
l'heure remy vittel est attaché à la
ruralité de son soûl go et à son
développement
nous connaissons tous aussi sa longue
expérience d'élu local
son sens du consensus et son attachement
au dynamisme de tous nos territoires
ainsi il a parfaitement su renforcer
leur attractivité comme l'a démontré
dernièrement la mise en place donc en
2019 de la nouvelle politique de
développement territorial voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui le groupe uni pour le haut
rhin a souhaité lui accorder toute sa
confiance en soutenant sa candidature à
la présidence du conseil départemental
du haut rhin
nous sommes parfaitement convaincu qu'il
saura remplir avec brio cette novlangue
qu'on nomme l'entreprise qui consiste à
apporter à nos populations
les services et les équipements
essentiels à la prospérité et au bien
vivre ensemble mais également à conduire
notre collectivité dans les meilleures
conditions vers la cea le président nous
a fixé les objectifs ce matin ils
méritent tous nos encouragements et nous
l'assurons de notre total soutien
merci pour votre attention
merci monsieur le président du groupe
uni pour le haut rhin est ce qu'il y à
d'autres intervenants
madame hélène merci monsieur le
président je prends la parole au nom du
groupe
udi indépendant en l'absence de notre
chef de groupe peuvent nicolas jander et
je voudrais tout d'abord m'associer très
largement et associer les orientations
nos deux groupes très largement aux
propos de notre collègue pierre bihl
mais je voudrais aussi madame la
ministre monsieur le président chers
collègues se féliciter très
chaleureusement notre collègue j'ai un
peu de mal à dire que l'aigle maintenant
je me le président rémi vite qu'ils
accèdent aujourd'hui donc à sa fonction
que j'espère bien qu'ils accèdent aux
fonctions de président du conseil
départemental et nous tenons à l'assuré
de notre soutien plein et entier dans la
mission qui est à présent la sienne pour
mener à bien nos politiques
départementales mais aussi et surtout
pour la mise en oeuvre opérationnelle de
notre collectivité européenne d'alsace
il se raconte et sur notre union pour
que l'équilibré l'avenir de tous les
territoires soient conformes aux
attentes de nos concitoyens
sa longue expérience et sa connaissance
fine d'une assemblée départementale nous
laisse à penser qu'il saura défendre les
intérêts de notre collectivité avec
détermination
l'alsace des territoires est une
philosophie à laquelle nous tenons tous
particulièrement nous avons tous ce goût
de la proximité qui nous a toujours
conduit à penser des politiques
intelligentes respectueuse
des enjeux et des spécificités de nos
cantons
nous savons qu'avec rémy vite à la tête
de notre assemblée nous avons comme avec
brigitte klinkert un leader un leader
garant de cet équilibre subtil et si
précieux après ces quelques mots de
félicitations cher monsieur le président
permettez moi de m'adresser maintenant à
celle qui est devenue aujourd'hui sa
première vice-présidente votre première
vice présidente madame la ministre
chère brigitte et nous te félicite très
chaleureusement pour ce poste auquel tu
as été nommé et que tu as très largement
mérité
je sais pas si je peux continuer à te
tutoyer beaucoup de respect mais c'est
un tue très respectueux tu as
aujourd'hui la lourde tâche de mener la
politique de l'insertion au sein du
gouvernement de notre pays dans un
contexte ô combien compliqué que nous
connaissons tous c'est une grande fierté
pour nous teyon vu à l'oeuvre dans ton
mandat de président de notre assemblée
nul ne doute de ton énergie et de ta
ténacité qui porteront leurs fruits au
nous au niveau national ça c'est juste
certains nous te remercions pour toute
l'attention que tu as porté à notre
département et pour le respect avec
lequel tu a gouverné pendant ces trois
années et nous ne doutons pas un seul
instant de ton engagement auprès du
gouvernement pour défendre notre alsace
dans l'attende a dans sa quête
d'efficacité de proximité renforcée et
tu y arriveras par le biais de cette
collectivité européenne d'alsace pour
laquelle tu attends vrai nous continuons
donc tous ensemble notre chemin pour le
haut-rhin et pour l'alsace et c'est dans
ces conditions que nous avons surmonté
les épreuves les unes après les autres
et c'est dans ces conditions que nous
démontrerons que même en politique
l'union fait la force merci
beaucoup marie france val a souhaité
intervenir
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le président chers collègues dans un
premier temps je voudrais vous féliciter
cheikh hamidi pour votre élection à la
tête de notre collectivité et vous
adresser tous mes meilleurs souhaits de
réussite pour la conduite de notre
assemblée dans cette période de
transition vers cette nouvelle
collectivité que nous avons appelée de
nos voeux
comme vous vous donnez nous le dira le
temps est court mais les enjeux sont
essentiels pour toute la population
alsacienne
nous avons donc été réunis une nouvelle
fois acquis à quatre mois de la création
de cette nouvelle collectivité pour
votre élection et ce pour une bonne
raison ce qui vient également d'être
rappelé par mes collègues qui ont
précédé puisque notre présidente
brigitte klinkert a été nommé récemment
prises ministre délégué à l'insertion
nous ne pouvons que nous en réjouir
collectivement puisque cette nomination
résulte à mon sens de ses compétences
nationalement reconnu par ses trois
années de fonction je voudrais vous en
féliciter madame la ministre une
nouvelle fois une ministre alsacienne
dans les rangs du gouvernement n'est pas
chaud aussi courantes que cela ait
qu'une femme alsacienne a été choisi me
fait particulièrement plaisir
nous savons également madame la ministre
parce que vous l'avez répété à de
nombreuses reprises que vous allez être
l'ambassadrice de tous les alsaciens et
dans le cadre de la création de la
nouvelle collectivité de son
fonctionnement
nous allons être observé non pas
seulement par tous les alsaciens mais
également par d'autres territoires
lors de la première visite de madame
gouro ministre des territoires en
septembre 2018 j'avais indiqué que
j'étais fortement attachés à cette
collectivité qui va être créé au 2
janvier 2021 au 1er janvier mais en
réalité
en raison de son histoire passée mais
également de son histoire à venir dans
le cadre de la construction européenne
en février 2019 je vous disais dans mon
intervention que l'avenir de notre
recolle activité restait à construire et
qu'ils étaient entre nos mains
j'espérais que nous pourrions tous y
prendre une part active afin que le
meilleur de nos deux politiques
départementales puissent être mises en
oeuvre dans l'intérêt de tous la
création de la nouvelle collectivité n'a
fait envoyer envisagé de rejoindre le
groupe politique comprenant les
personnes adhérant à lui d i et les
indépendants je souhaite en effet
participé activement à la construction
de la cia pour que celle ci reste une
collectivité de proximité au service de
l'ensemble des alsaciens de manière tout
à fait équilibré sans esprit partisan
pour le bas rhin ou pour le haut-rhin et
pour cela il me semble que nous devons
inventer ensemble à nouveau modèle dans
tous les cas il est de notre devoir à
tous de faire tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir pour que cette collectivité
réussissent et soit réellement au
service de tous ainsi chaque voix
comptera je souhaite m'engager
clairement dans cette voie il s'agit
pour moi de participer à la réflexion
collective et partagée et je crois qu'il
reste du travail sur la planche dans une
démarche constructive ayant démissionné
du parti socialiste en février 2018
je me présente dans le groupe e dei et
indépendant présidé donc par nico
nicolas jander en tant qu'élu
indépendante
je n'ai pas changé et j'ai conservé les
valeurs qui sont les miennes des valeurs
humanistes et sociales que je n'ai pas
cessé d'exprimer depuis le début de
notre mandat
je me réjouis de pouvoir participer
activement à la construction de la cea
dans les mois à venir
le temps est compté et le projet de
notre collectivité rentrer dans le
concret elles nécessitent l'énergie de
tous merci
[Applaudissements]
merci marie france d'autres prises de
parole monsieur tri mari oui j'aurais
souhaité à l'écouté des différents
discours m'exprimer solidairement bien
entendu mais peut-être avec un petit
complément de deux messages
bien entendu je m'associe aux
félicitations qui ont été exprimés comme
kirby l'a dit c'est une séance
historique puisque nous venons délire
le dernier président du conseil
départemental du haut-rhin dernier les
boues peu pour que qu'il ne soit pas
nominée ministre entre temps
[Rires]
mais mon message et surtout deux
suivants donc un pourrait croire qu'il
s'agit d'une présidence de transition
or je pense que cette présidence fait
l'objet d'une véritable exigence qui
doit en faire une présidence de
construction une présidence de
protection et une présidence
d'innovation une présidence de
construction parce que comme cela a été
rappelé nous sommes en phase de
construction de la collectivité
européenne d'alsace
rappelez-vous nous avons trouvé le moyen
innovant de répondre au désir d'alsace
qu'exprimait fortement nos concitoyens
mais ce qu'il est important de rappeler
c'est que nous y avons répondu en
évitant d'aller dans le sens du repli
sur soi mais plutôt en faisant en sorte
que l'alsace puise devenir l'avant garde
de ce qui fera avancer la france et
l'europe de demain
et si je rappelle ça c'est parce qu'il
faut toujours que l'on veille et ce sera
aussi de votre responsabilité monsieur
le président de ne pas et de ne jamais
se tromper de débat
si nous avons inventé de toutes pièces
un concept de concept de la collectivité
européenne asa ce qui est une nouvelle
collectivité
reste maintenant à la réaliser à la
concrétiser ce qui revient à devoir
résoudre une équation qui est facile à
poser mais qui est difficile à résoudre
à savoir faire converger les politiques
départementales en ne faisant que des
gagnants
en tout cas en faisant en sorte qu'il
n'y ait aucun perdant dans les limites
madame
présidente aux finances d'un budget
maîtrisé
autant chercher à résoudre la quadrature
du cercle
nous allons y arriver mais nous n'y
arriverons que si nous sommes innovant
président de protection dans la
situation sanitaire que nous connaissons
la crise sanitaire elle n'est pas
terminée nous sommes et nous demeurons
en pleine crise sanitaire l'épidémie
ayant d'ailleurs tendance à se réactive
et on ne parle à ce propos dans les
médias que du masque mais le masque qui
masque des visages ne doit pas masquer
la réalité le problème qui se pose
aujourd'hui n'est pas que sanitaire même
s'il est important il est vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le président social il
est également sociétale vous avez cité
la question de précarité à laquelle il
va falloir faire face
parce qu'elles risquent de se développer
vous avez cité la question de la
jeunesse qu'il va falloir accompagner
dans cette période mais moi je souhaite
également ajouté un enjeu fondamental
qui est apparue d'autant plus renforcée
à travers cette crise à savoir l'enjeu
des personnes âgées et notamment de ce
qui se passe au niveau des ehpad
la question est de savoir comment il
gérait la sécurité sanitaire en évitant
un mal
tout aussi grave qui est l'isolément et
c'est ce qu'on a vu au moment du
confinement
nous devrons donc travailler
collectivement à inventer un nouveau
modèle qui permettent aux personnes
âgées et notamment aux pensionnaires des
ehpad d'être ouvert sur la société et
même de s'y voir reconnaître une place
active tout en étant protégé
je pense qu'il y a un enjeu
deux sociétés très important est
évidemment au delà du sujet des
personnes âgées et des ehpad la question
à laquelle nous avons à faire face c'est
de savoir comment nous allons pouvoir
vivre avec le virus et cela reste à
inventer président de construction
présidente protection mais également un
président d'innovation dans le cadre de
la crise économique qui est induite par
la crise sanitaire crise économique
ne vous leurrez pas qui est en train de
se déclarer tous les signaux la teste
ce qui est inquiétant face à cette
situation nous devons bien évidemment
faire bloc haut rhin et bas rhin en
synergie avec tous les acteurs concernés
qu'ils soient institutionnels ou privés
et bien entendu la future collectivité
européenne d'alsace mais nous devons y
faire face en faisant paradoxalement de
cette situation une opportunité c'est à
dire en renforçant le tissu économique
de notre ville de notre territoire pour
qu'ils soient à l'avenir plus résistant
et en anticipant ce que seront les
opportunités de demain
de sorte que les acteurs économiques
concernés soit prêt le moment venu
bref nous devons travailler à passer la
crise en faisant en sorte d'en sortir
renforcé
dans ce contexte la marque alsace qui
est gérée aujourd'hui par l'adira un
rôle majeur à jouer à savoir donner
envie d'alsace en mettant en avant ce
qui est fondamentalement l'alsace
éternelle avec ses valeurs de sérieux
d'exigence de qualité et d'ouverture aux
autres et je vous l'annonçais ça marche
depuis le 1er juillet la marque alsace a
dépassé
les 2 5 millions d'abonnés sur les
réseaux sociaux
ces publications ont été vus 21 millions
de fois soit 10 % de plus par rapport à
la même période en 2010 9 et mieux
encore ces publications en même temps
généré 1 million de réaction positif que
ce soit des lacs des partages ou des
commentaires soit 27 % de plus par
rapport à la même période en 2010 9 bref
l'alsace a la cote
il faut le savoir et c'est ce qui en
fait un territoire d'avenir
à nous de contribuer solidairement et
efficacement à concrétiser cet avenir en
faisant de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace l'outil de son développement et
de sa prospérité pour cela monsieur le
président vous pouvez compter sur nous
autant que nous comptons sur vous merci
merci merci et philippe d'autres
demandes de parole madame la ministre
premier vice président du conseil
départemental
monsieur le président chers collègues
toutes mes félicitations cher président
chers amis pour votre élection
je sais vos profonde qualités humaines
et aussi vos très grandes capacités et
qualités de travail elles seront
précieuses pour notre assemblée et pour
notre collectivité
je sais qu'avec vous le conseil
départemental du haut rhin est entre de
bonnes mains
vous pouvez compter sur moi à vos côtés
dans l'exercice de cette mission
exigeante et passionnante
vous pouvez compter sur moi comme j'ai
pu compter sur vous
cher président chers collègues je tiens
également à vous remercier pour votre
confiance première vice présidente en
charge de l'alsace et de son ouverture à
l'international c'est pour moi une
fierté et un honneur que de poursuivre
avec vous la construction de cette belle
collectivités européennes d'alsace
puisque nous sommes plus que jamais
garant collectivement de la réussite de
ce beau projet et à ce titre et à la
place qui est la mienne je m'en sens
aussi plus que jamais
garante chers collègues merci pour les
mots que vous avez sûrs à mon égard cela
a été un honneur et un grand bonheur
vraiment de présider l'assemblée
départementale du haut-rhin pendant près
de trois années à la suite d'eric
straumann
aujourd'hui c'est pour moi une fierté et
un honneur que de représenter l'alsace
haut au sein du gouvernement de la
france et c'est une fierté et un honneur
que de pouvoir continuer à agir à vos
côtés
ici dans cette alsace qui ne cesse
jamais d'habiter bon car ministre de
l'insertion ma feuille de route est de
ne laisser personne au bord du chemin
c'est une préoccupation que nous
partageons ici et qui constitue
également une ligne directrice pour la
collectivité européenne d'alsace je suis
ministre
mais je reste aussi une élue de terrain
et je le dis chaque jour une élue de
terre a ancré sur mon territoire
européenne convaincue et passionnément
alsacienne alors cher président chers et
milite
chers collègues plus que jamais unie et
soudée pour les haut-rhinois y pour les
alsaciens je me réjouis vraiment de
continuer à oeuvrer ensemble pour
l'alsace je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la ministre pour tous ses
encouragements
j'aurai besoin de vous à mes côtés c'est
certain comme nous avons travaillé en
binôme nous je l'espère nous
continuerons à avancer en binôme pour
pouvoir répondre à vos attentes à tous
et surtout aux attentes de nos
populations
je crois que comme philippe l'a très
bien souligné nous sommes nous sommes
dans la construction de quelque chose
d'innovant et d'une collectivité
exemplaire qui doit préfigurer ce que
l'institution française pourra faire de
bien et de mieux merci bien
pas d'autres intervenants je vais donc
on va donc passer aux rapports si vous
le voulez bien
et l'ordre du jour prévoit certains de
rapports je vais donner la parole à
pierre bihl pour la présentation des
rapports
ils et elles dépendent plus ou moins de
la 12e commission et il en est le
président s'il veut bien nous les
présenter merci merci à toi président
donc nous sommes au troisième rapport
dont qui concerne les délégations du
conseil départemental donc à la
commission permanente donc un certain
nombre dans un certain nombre de
domaines domaines qui sont listées dans
le rapport et dont vous avez pu prendre
connaissance
ce n'est pas les reprendre tous s'il ya
des questions évidemment vous pouvez les
proposer et s'il y en a page propose au
président que du passé à la délibération
et au vote
oui est ce qu'il y à des oppositions à
l'adoption de ce rapport à d'opposition
des abstentions le rapport est approuvé
je vous remercie voilà donc nous
poursuivons avec le 4ème rapport qui lui
même du même style puisque il concerne
les délégations qui sont donnés au
président du conseil départemental et là
aussi dans le rapport pour retrouver
l'ensemble des délégations donc qui sont
concerné et qu'il y a lieu donc
d'approuver
ce matin à la présidence
la beauté voilà comme il s'agit des
délégations président c'est à moi de
vous soumettre le rapport aux voix qui
ce qui est contre qui est-ce qui
s'abstient rapport adopté
je vous remercie chers collègues ce
merci prix gîte donc je poursuis
président du rdr au cinquième rappeur
qui concerne les commissions du conseil
départemental et donc il ya donc les
commissions qui fonctionnait jusqu'à
présent dont quito qu'on a prévu
évidemment de poursuivre ce
fonctionnement et vous avez dans le
rapport donc la liste de ces commissions
pour la lire que voulez lire donc les
commissions s'articule de la façon
suivante première commission finances et
budget donc à présidente c'est la
ramillon vice-présidente rapporteur
général du budget fabienne orlandi
deuxième commission aménagement du
territoire et du tourisme président
nicolas jander vice président rapporteur
il aimait d'hier troisième commission
route voirie et infrastructures
président donc à lagrave vice président
rapporteur lucien muller quatrième
commission solidarité autonomie
président de la commission à la couche
au vice présidente rapporteur karine
pagliarulo la cinquième commission
patrimoine immobilier actions et
territoires présidents de commissions
rémy vite vice-présidente rapporteur
monique martin sixième commission
agriculture environnement et cadre de
vie président michel habig
vice-présidente rapporteur annick
lutenbacher septième commission culture
et patrimoine présidente bernadette
groff vice-présidente rapporteur emilie
elle d'art les huitièmes commission
éducation et jeunesse président pierre
vox vice-présidente rapporteur
bernadette groff la 9ème commission
sport et vie associative président marc
schittly
présidente rapporteur et midi elle
d'aller la 10e commission solidarité
famille insertion et logement présidente
de la commission fatima yens
vice-présidente rapporteur patricia
bonne la 11e commission action relations
internationales et promotion du
bilinguisme président daniel adrian
vice-présidente rapporteur pascale
schmidiger et enfin à la 12è commission
administration générale des ressources
humaines président pierre bihl
vice-présidente rapporteur fabienne
orlandi on vous rappelle que le
président du conseil départemental et
est membre de droit de chacune des
commissions et qu'à l'occasion de la
séance publique chaque conseiller
départemental donc s'inscrit dans le la
ou les commissions thématiques de son
choix
ou alors vous y restèrent puisque vous y
êtes
dans la plupart la liste détaillant la
composition de chacune de ces
commissions sur un excès à délibération
et il y a lieu monsieur le président
donc à délibérer merci la liste
d'inscription à ces commissions
circulent je crois vous pouvez vous vous
inscrire pour que l'on puisse compléter
m en annexe cette liste
la délibération qui vous a été soumise
je vous la soumet au vote
est-ce que sur le rapport qui vous est
proposée sur les compositions des
commissions
il y à des oppositions je n'en vois pas
il ya des objections ou des abstentions
je n'en vois pas non plus le rapport est
donc approuvée
très bien alors pas se propose de passer
donc aux rapports aussi ce qui concerne
la désignation des conseillers délégués
dans les commissions thématiques donc là
aussi on vous propose de re désignés
dont les conseillers qui était de touche
lui de toutes et tous en place je
m'appelle les personnes qui sont
concernées donc patricia bonne les
différentes missions de chacune et de
chacun donc pour patricia bonne
observation et pilotage des politiques
de l'enfance en lien avec les
territoires
martin dietrich le dialogue
interreligieux
sabine drexler jeunesse citoyenneté
engagement pascal ferrari numérique
recherche et innovation emilie helderlé
développement durable yves hemedinger
sécurité et prévention de la
radicalisation et des comportements à
risque annick lutenbacher montagne
massif vosgien marque mots que qualité
de vie et sécurité des agents travail
innovation et création dans l'action
publique
fabienne orlandi l'emploi catherine rap
égalité lutte contre les discriminations
pascale schmidiger actions et relations
internationales ainsi que le bilinguisme
et philippe trimaille impacts des
politiques départementales sur l'emploi
et l'activité
ok s'agissant de
délégation ou de conseiller délégué je
vais faire la chose envers je vais vous
faire voter à main levée qui est
favorable
merci qui s'opposent qui s'abstient
personnes les collègues sont donc
désigné dans leur délégation
voilà donc face aux rapports 7 qui
concerne l'élection des membres de la
commission d'appel d'offres du jury de
concours de la commission de délégation
de service public et de la commission
interne des marchés à procédure donc
adapter le présent rapport a pour objet
d'élire les membres titulaires et
suppléants du conseil départemental donc
au sein de la commission d'appel
d'offres du jury de concours de la
commission de délégation de service
public et de la commission interne des
marchés à procédure adaptée
donc je vous rappelle les personnes qui
sont concernées donc titulaire michel
habig marque moon que pierre bock
patricia bonne fabienne orlandi et un
suppléant donc marie-france mal à betty
muller pierre bihl lara million et eric
straumann
donc voilà les éléments que j'ai donc il
vous est proposé d'élire sa conseillers
départementaux titulaires et cinq
conseillers départementaux suppléant
qu'aux membres de la commission d'appel
d'offres et de la commission interne des
marchés à procédure adaptée et dire ça
conseiller département titulaires et
cinq conseils des papes départementaux
suppléant comme membre du jury de
concours et enfin élire cinq conseillers
départementaux titulaires et cinq
conseils départementaux suppléant comme
membre de la commission de délégation
des services publics vient merci je vais
également c'est une commission qui est
très encadrée par les textes un
commission d'appel d'offres je vais
également faire voter à main levée sur
la composition de cette commission
êtes vous d'accord avec les personnes
proposées
merci y at il des oppositions y at il
des abstentions ce n'est pas le cas je
tiens à vous préciser que je désignerai
spécialement que je déléguerait
particulièrement à la présidence de la
commission d'appel d'offres jury
concours et la délégation de service
public
et des marchés en procédure adaptée le
collègue lucien muller qui a exercée
jusqu'ici et qui est tout à fait
d'accord à continuer à poursuivre cette
mission il sera donc le président de la
commission d'appel d'offres merci voilà
huitième rapport donc qui concerne la
désignation des représentants du conseil
départemental conseil d'administration
du luxe 10,68 donc le présent rapport a
pour objet la désignation des quatorze
représentants titulaires et donc il y à
14 représentant suppléant du département
au sein du ca du sdiss que vous rappelle
également les indices des collègues qui
sont qui sont concernés donc les membres
titulaires rémy vite pierre bihl
président klinkert pascale schmidiger
annick lutenbacher betty muller michel
habib karine kadi pas de bière hulot va
sans aucune barre
monique martin à la grappe nicolas
jander lara million et pierre bock
démordre suppléant daniel adrian pascal
ferrari hemedinger fabien orlandi marque
moon que philippe trimaille bernadette
groff martin dietrich du siamu l'air
emilie helderlé sabine drexler max
delmond josiane mehlen vetter et
catherine rap lien
là aussi il s'agit de désignation donc
je souhaite aussi que l'on botte
à main levée qui est favorable à la
désignation de nos collègues
merci tout le monde il y at il des
oppositions y at il des abstentions ce
n'est pas le cas que vous informe
également que le président du casdis et
de droit le président du conseil
départemental qui pourrait déléguer
éventuellement cette cette fonction mais
pour diverses raisons j'ai décidé de
rester président du casdis comme l'a été
brigitte auparavant ça permet aussi de
poursuivre le travail qui a été engagé
avec le colonel directeur du spis merci
je poursuis neuvième rapport dont qui
concerne la désignation des
représentants du conseil départemental
pour siéger au sein des organismes
extérieurs
donc ce rapport a pour objet de procéder
à cette désignation
on vous rappelle aussi que la liste des
représentations du conseil départemental
a été communiquée donc en annexe du
présent du présent rapport que nous
avons examiné également en réunion
préparatoire et un intergroupe tout à
l'heure l'assemblée peu décidé à
l'unanimité de ne pas recourir au vote à
bulletin secret au profit du vote à main
levée en vue de désigner ses
représentants par voie électronique
assez plusieurs candidatures étaient
proposées pour un même poste
représentant ou de déléguer l'assemblée
devra alors recourir au vote à bulletin
secret apparemment encore une fois on
étudier les différentes affectations
donc en règle à préparatoire au score
qu'il soit indispensable de rhdp der
veer non tout non je crois que gilles
ans a pu consulter tout à fait monsieur
président de commission
chacun a pu consulter je pense vous avez
reçu dans les rapports la liste elle n'a
pas changé depuis l'an bois je demande
quand même si quelqu'un souhaitait
modifier quelque chose ou être
différemment candidat à l'une ou l'autre
des rubriques un compte
vous gardez tous plus ou moins vous vous
attributions et vos représentations dans
les différents organismes
ce qui a finalement changé c'est les les
attributions qu'avait madame la ministre
et moi même par rapport à nos nouvelles
nouvelles fonctions maintenant et puis
on a profité pour mettre aussi à jour là
la suite à l'élection municipale la
situation de l'un ou l'autre des
collègues qui siège aujourd'hui en tant
que maire dans ces organismes ne peut
plus siéger en tant que délégué
départemental est-ce que sur le rapport
sur ces désignations je vais également
vous demander de lever la main ceux qui
sont favorables
c'est un peu embêtant mais c'est des
délégations des désignations ou être
carré pas d'opposition pas de
l'abstention merci à vous c'est moi qui
vais prendre le relais pour le rapport
le 10e il s'agit de désigner un
conseiller départemental pour
représenter le département dans les
actes administratifs qui sont établies
par le président du conseil
départemental dans le cadre donc la
passation de ces actes concernant les
droits immobiliers ainsi que les bots
passé en la forme administrative par le
département il ya lieu donc de désigner
celui qui signe pour le compte du
département puisque le président étant
officiers ministériels reçoit l'acte
fait fonction de notaire si vous
préférez et donc
pour représenter le département il nous
faut désigner un collègue généralement
c'est un vice président je vous propose
donc ça a été vue que ce soit monsieur
pierre bihl qu'ils puissent bénéficier
de ce mandat de représentation de la
collectivité départementale à cette
occasion yat il est ce que vous êtes
favorable merci de lever les mains est
ce qu'il ya des oppositions y at il des
abstentions ce n'est pas le cas monsieur
bill est désigné merci président merci à
vous toutes et tous
je termine par le onzième rapport de
notre séance de ce matin qui concerne
donc les moyens mis à disposition des
conseillers départementaux
vous pouvez constater dans le rapport
que c'est des moyens qui sont mis à
disposition évidemment du président des
vice présidents mais aussi des
conseillers départementaux
donc voilà il y a lieu de valider
également ce ce matin donc ce rapport
d'accord c'est en gros ce qui se
pratiquait dans la collectivité on n'a
rien changé aux quasiment rien et donc
on continue à fonctionner ainsi je tiens
juste à préciser que les dix présidents
qui sont en charge de certaines missions
spécifiques qui nécessitent
régulièrement des déplacements dans le
département mais aussi en dehors du
département ont donc une voiture de
service à leur disposition que tient
aussi à le souligner parce que
il ya eu j'ai lu et j'ai entendu
quelques commentaires à ce sujet que les
conseillers département où les vice
présidents ou un conseil départemental
qui doit représenter notre collectivité
sur une mission particulière qui
nécessite un déplacement assez
importants ou sur une mission spécifique
mais ponctuelles pour assure
autorisation du président avoir un
chauffeur pour l'emmener à cette réunion
ça ne sera pas je le dis tout de suite
pas systématique c'est vraiment sur des
missions vraiment précises ponctuelles
je pense notamment les schémas régionaux
où il faut aller représenter la
collectivité parce que voilà des
déplacements souvent ce n'est pas les
lui tout seul qui ait conduit il ya
parfois aussi le directeur ou les
représentants de l'administration qui
sont en charge du sujet qui l'accompagné
c'est souvent du covoiturage qui se fait
donc voilà en tout cas il y aura il n'y
a pas de débordements à attendre sur
cette affaire je serais très très
vigilant et très strictes messieurs
trimaille oui c'était c'était une
question me convenait d'y répondre en
partie tels vous pouvez préciser
question que je me posais cet usage
l'évolution des usages à qui est proposé
vous confirmez bien qu'il se fait à
moyens constants et qu'il consiste en
une optimisation de l'utilisation des
moyens actuels tout à fait je peux vous
rassurer
on n'achète pas de voitures de plus on
n'embauche pas de plus de chauffeurs etc
il n'y a pas de ceux ci nous serons dans
le strict budget et dans la stricte
poursuite de ce que de ce qui se faisait
sauf que il faut officiellement délibéré
pour pouvoir valider juridiquement la
pratique voilà sur le rapport
est ce qu'il y à je préfère aussi qu'on
vote à main levée est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
merci c'est une unanimité y at il des
oppositions y at il des abstentions ce
n'est pas le cas le rapport est donc
approuvée
je vous remercie je crois qu'on est
arrivé au terme de nos rapports et en
même temps au terme de notre séance de
ce matin il est midi pile
nous avons à peu près tenu le timing
malgré leur obligatoire d'interruption
de séance qu'il a fallu respecter tout
cas je vous remercie toutes et tous de
votre participation
du consensus qui s'est dégagé ce matin
de cette assemblée
je me sens encore plus investie de la
mission au vu de votre soutien et de
votre témoignage de sympathie
permettez moi de vous dire que comme je
l ai déjà dit je vais pas refaire mon
discours mais j'essayerai d'être à la
hauteur de la tâche
je sais qu'elle sera difficile qu'elle
sera lourde que même si ces quatre mois
elle sera aussi longue longue dans la
journée sans doute et même les nuits
voir les week-ends je sais j'ai tel
témoin le témoin physique de ce que
brigitte avant moi a dû à du dû dégager
ou du généré en investissement et en
énergie je sais ce que la tâche attend
de moi je vais essayer d'être de must de
mud être digne de cette mission tout cas
merci à vous et puis je conclus là
dessus à moins que quelqu'un souhaite
encore intervenir s'il y en pour une
intervention non jeu je vais juste vous
rappeler je vais conclure la séance donc
la séance est levée